hi
i'm simona and i work at hiku and this
presentation is about
learning from your model's mistakes
first few words on data cure the taiko
has been founded in 2013
by four french guys and it's today
headquartered in the us
the reiko provides a data science
platform uh which works
across all industries across the globe
it's for enterprise ai
and since last year that iko is also a
unicorn
we're growing we're currently hiring so
don't hesitate to have a look at the
offers on our website
and so machine learning models make
mistakes
and model debugging and error analysis
are necessary steps in the iterative
process of model design
any data scientist after training a
machine learning model needs to
investigate
its failures to understand which
subpopulation the model is performing
poorly
he needs to build intuition about what
are the problematic features correlated
with the error and what are the
feature feature values typical of
failures
usually this kind of analysis is
performed manually but this is
ineffective and time consuming
so here we focus on how to provide data
scientists with an automatic
tool to simplify model error analysis
the first key step behind model error
analysis is to break down the error
because there might be several reasons
why a machine learning model is
making mistakes and if we try to
treat all the error as a whole it's
actually quite difficult to make sense
of it
if you um imagine to take all the
misclassified force in the popular mnist
dataset for instance
it's very difficult to understand what's
going on there but if you consider
if you group the different predictions
by predicted class you could
make sense of the error that is behind
it for instance some force they look
like nine some four look like seven etc
so actually segmenting the errors in
meaningful clusters
allows to have an easier analysis
and actually model performance
predictors are also mpp
they can help automatize this step
so let's see how performance predictor
work
first we have a primary model under
investigation so it's the primary model
we're studying for instance you can take
a
primary model that is predicting the
price of houses
and so this primary model also has an
associated set
and we compute the prediction of the
primary model on the test set and we
categorize it
as either a success or a failure
then we have a secondary model that is
our model performance predictor
so it's a binary classification model
that is trained on the test set features
and also on this binary categorization
of the prediction as either a success or
a failure
and so this secondary model is trained
to predict whether the model the primary
model succeeds
or whether it fails usually we take a
decision tree classifier as a model
performance predictor
because it's easier to interpret and so
this decision
tree would uh will cluster different
type of errors in
failure segments those are the the
decision tree nodes
and so each node group samples with
similar features some other performances
and actually a fellow not represents a
specific
different kind of error and so those are
meant to be studied individually
and to simplify the analysis
model performance predictor exists for
both classification and regression tasks
if we have a classification
classification task
the failure is defined as a wrong
predictor class
but we could also go deeper in the
analysis and maybe categorize
any failed predictions as
like a false positive or a false
negative per class
if we have a regression task the failure
is defined a bit different is a large
deviation of the prediction from the
actual value
and this definition requires also
defining a tolerance threshold
above which the deviation defines a
failure
and this is computed as a knee point of
the regression error characteristic
curve or the regression model
and this allows actually that the
absolute error of primary prediction
stays within tolerable limits for those
predictions that we defined as success
also here in regression we could
consider more levels of error and not
only a
binary threshold
now we have built a model performance
predictor and we need also to gather
information from it together some
insights about
the error behind
so the mvp can actually have a complex
structures
many nodes and we need to highlight the
data that is relevant to failure and
discard all the rest
so how can we do this automatically
first we can select the most important
failure nodes by
size and purity and then when we have a
look at one specific failure node
we can look at the features correlated
with the error
so those ones we can gather them
for instance by ranking the features by
the performance predictor feature
importance
which in case of a decision tree is the
mean increase of impurity
but we can also have a finer analysis if
we take
importance measure that are local to the
node
and so those gives us those give us
the critical features for a specific
group of errors
and one example of doing this is to use
the mean shot values of the samples
inside that fall under a specific
failure node
one important tool to get insights from
the
model performance predictor is this
discriminating discriminative local
versus global
analysis in particular we can compare
all the symbols that are in a failure
node
against the global population which is
mainly successful
if we've done a good job with the model
and so this could be like a baseline a
background
against which we compare what's going on
in the fader node
so if we look at the distribution of the
critical features in the node versus
this global successful population
if there are differences we can have an
idea
what are the subpopulation on which the
model is failing like in this example if
we take back the example of a model
a primary model predicting the price of
houses here we could
understand that the model is failing to
predict the price
for houses with very large living rooms
maybe because
these are underrepresented in our
training set
we are using models that usually they
are trained on preprocessed features and
actually pre-process features are not
good for interpretability as you can
guess
and in general model debugging on
preprocessed data is not ideal
so what we need to do is to use um some
tools for instance circular pipeline
to undo this preprocessing and to
visualize
the human readable feature values and
this allows to have a
clear explanation what's going on for
instance in this same illustration that
we have here as before about
the surface of the living rooms we have
negative numbers so it could be
even a little bit misleading and we can
be puzzled by this
visualization instead if we can undo the
preprocessing we will have a
clear human readable value
and so now it's time to connect the dots
and put all together
if you are interested in modulator
analysis you can
perform this procedure i explained in
this presentation but you can also
use an open source package that we are
publishing soon
that uh for provides an error analysis
tool for secular models
and it also supports pipeline models so
it
provides an error analyzer to analyze
the model and train a
model performance predictor and also
another visualizer to display
the performance predictor tree and also
feature distributions
as i said it supports pipeline so you
can in fu line of codes you can
instantiate an error analyzer on both
encyclone or a pipeline model and
to train um to fit it assets to train
and model performance predictor
and afterward you can use the visualizer
to visualize
both the error tree and features
distributions
and this package automatically the
failure nodes
more important they are highlighted and
also the feature that are more
correlated with the error are
automatically highlighted
also um you must be aware that actually
a model performance predictor
is a predictor of performances so you
can also use it as a model
on new data that is not uh labeled
and you could get hints about um your
primary model performance on this new
data
like for instance in this example you
could say a look those observations your
model will probably fail here
and this is useful information in
particular if we put all together so we
have a train model for a start
and we fit a decision tree on the errors
in the test set to build our performance
predictor
then we can have a look at the segment
at the failures notes and
we can have a look at the features that
are more correlated with the error in
those failure nodes
at this point we have two options either
we
gather enough information to go back to
model design or maybe to improve our
data collection process or we can still
use
our model of new data to predict
possible
failure on some data and then we can
select this data and send for instance
for manual inspection instead
so here i put some references for the
model performance predictor for the
couriers readers
but you can also ask any question you
have in mind now
and thanks for watching